*sonnerie*
- Bonjour !
- Bonjour
- J'ai un colis pour euh. .. Norman ... faite ... dès vi... ?
- Ouais c'est moi ! C'est bon c'est moi merci
Bonne journée!
- Attendez, attendez
Et y'a ça aussi...
*bruit de chute*
- Bonjour à tous, alors je vous ai proposé
de m'envoyer des colis par le biais de la Poste,
afin de les ouvrir dans une vidéo YouTube,
et bien ça y est, on est dans la vidéo YouTube, et donc je vais les ouvrir avec ce couteau, de criminel...
Tah tah tah
Tiens, génial, un énorme sifflet,
imagine le mec à la piscine...
OH! *( souffle dans le sifflet, bruit de hibou)*
C'est pour les maîtres nageurs hiboux,
Oh, ça c'est excellent, mini basket
OoOoh, des criquets morts,
Oh c'est mort je mange pas ça c'est sûr!
- J'te jure, si je le fais tu le fais!
Franchement c'est comme des chips gros,
Je te jure c'est des chips.
- J've pas toucher putain!
Attend-ttend-ttend....
- Non mais croque vraiment!
- Mais je croque là...
- Arrête de faire l'escroc *rires*
- Ah c'est ultra mauvais!
*rires* Une paire de couilles pour ton vélo, ça tue
Merlin? -Yeah, les bonne couilles de chat!
Du dentifrice au bacon,
Est-ce-qu'on peut utiliser quand on est Musulman?
C'est un dentifrice essaye!
- Ah putain mais absolument pas ! Déjà je suis plus Musulman à avoir fait ça
-Est-ce-que tu peux quand t'es végétarien?
Oh, un mini-golf pour toilette,
quand t'es en train de faire ta grosse commission!
Excusez-moi, tu peut fermer la porte s'il te plaît!
-Merci!
Waouw, ça c'est vraiment un kit pour le chat quoi
Une petite souris, un concombre, parce que c'est très connu que les chats ont peur des concombres.
Et ce n'est pas une blague en plus!
On pose le concombre sans qu'il le voit,
*rires* Il s'en bat les couilles...
Un Action-Man, PUBG
"Ouvre sa chemise, et tu verras qu'il est plus musclé que toi!"
Des pa ci to !
Un coussin péteur !
On essaye ?
C'est un silencieux!
Putain, c'est des bières artisanales, mais je vais en donner à toute l'équipe des bières.
Buvez un maximum! Le cadre risque d'être un peu tremblant!
Très réussi merci pour ce cadeau EMPOISONNÉ!!
Mon parquet!
C'est l'une des meilleures bières que j'ai jamais bu de ma vie.
Par contre il aurait peut-être pu envoyer la serpillière avec...
Génial, des gros ballons en forme de lettres,
qui forme le mot : Norman!
Ou alors, Mano!
Ou alors, Mazo!
Ou alors, Maron, La couleur du caca
Ou encore, Zazo,
qui ne veut rien dire.
Apparemment cette petite chatte s'appelle Réglisse!
La version femelle de Merlin!
Les plumes, alors laisse-tomber comment il va kiffer!
Si vous voulez faire kiffer Merlin, envoyez-lui des plumes!
Il est plumiste en fait à la base!
Ouii!
Alors ça c'est un vêtement pour Merlin!
Je sens d'avance, qu'il va pas du tout apprécier!
Il a l'air vraiment heureux!
🎵Allez, viens boire un p'tit coup à la maison, 🎵
🎵 Y a du blanc, y a du rouge du saucisson, 🎵
🎵 Y'a Gillou avec son p'tit accordéon 🎵
Et voilà tu es libéré!
Apparemment c'est des objets d'un site pour adultes
C'est une brebis gonflable,
T'ain pour vous je suis aussi désespéré à ce point,
Et donc il y a derrière un trou pour mettre euh son...
son sexe! J'ai pas envie d’essayer!
Des pailles en forme de zizi fluorescentes
🎵(Musique de The X-Files) 🎵
Nous sommes les phallus venus d'ailleurs dans le but de détruire l'humanité.
Devinez celle-la!
*Musique de GameOfThrones*
De l'argent imprimé sur du Sopalin!
Yeah, YouTube Money!
Un reste de Marshmallow!
Putain les radins!
Oh un petit yoyo, donc cette personne pense que j'ai huit ans!
Quand j'étais en 6è j'ai pécho avec ça!
Bon, bah je l'ai cassé!
Une machine à...donner des "punchs" (coups-de-poings) c'est énorme!
Pour info c'est très peu puissant!
Un petit paper toy de moi-même!
Réalisé par...notre ami Jules!
Ça c'est Merlin, même si on dirait un..., une bûche!
Oh des petite oreilles de "biatch".
Oh les bonbons qu'on donne gratuit dans les hôtels!
Il m'a fait un colis Amazon avec des trucs LiveJasmine, les trucs de webcam de cul
De la Cocaïne!
C'est génial! C'est un kit de LockPicking
Pour apprendre à déverrouiller des serrures!
C'est trop beau!
Oh un petit chameau!  arbi aid mubarek
Yes la petite figurine Pop
de Negan de Walking Dead!
Personnage qui dans ma vidéo Walking Dead
est incarné par ... Raphaël Descraques! Bien ouéj
Une voiture ayant appartenu à Adolf Hitler
ça n'a pas du tout marché!
Je comprends pourquoi il me l'a offert!
Attention une peinture complétement psyché'
Très très beau!
Putain un PédoBear
Merlin tiens!
*rires* Un truc pour s’épiler!
Je, je n'ai pas de poil !
Qu'est-ce que tu veux que je m'épile ?
Cette vidéo est un fiasco, mon appartement est totalement souillé
Putain!!
Un parquet à la bière!
C'est un dessin de la part d'Esther!
Je crois que c'est la première fois qu'on me dessine avec de la barbe...
Je suis passé dans le cap des barbus?
Je crois que je vais l'accrocher!
C'est une Barbie Norman!
Qui est faite pour qu'on touche ses seins!
95E
Une araignée pour se gratter la tête!
Je suis en orgasme capillaire là!
Des protéines pour tes muscles petits et flasques!
Je le prends très très bien!
Les gens envoient des objets je sais même pas comment les décrire...
tellement c'est improbable!
Là c'est un sorte de pot fait maison..
en coton!
merci Alexia!
Un petit Emoji!
En plus c'est mon emoji...l'un de mes favoris!
Qu'est-ce-qui a Merlin? Tu veux qu'on ouvre cette enveloppe?
Des croquettes pour Merlin!
C'est pour ça que tu voulais l'ouvrir cette pochette Merlin
Apparemment il kiffe!
Un Diamond Button de YouTube!
Pour les dix millions d'abonnés en pâte à sel!
Alors ça c'est des produits pour perdre du poids!
Je suis pas le seul à avoir remarqué que...que j'avais grossi...
Un colis de forme cylindrique!
Limite ce que je préfère c'est la boîte!
Merci à Alienor pour cette magnifique peinture!
Avec un petit style impressionniste!
*cite les vidéos dessinées*
Que des vidéos, plutôt périmées !
C'est une perruque?
Y a pas un sens pour la perruque?
Putain, une petite montre hé!
ça tue!
Merci les gars!
Hey, des HandSpinner!
Un moi en produit de récupération,
le jean c'est un vrai truc en jean!
une bombe de peinture et mes cheveux ils sons en...fils de fer...
Merci Maxime, pour ce petit talent d'Artiste!
Une mouette, je sais pas quel commentaire faire...
On m'a offert l'album de Selena Gomez
J'aime bien Selena Gomez, je trouve que musicalement est hyper bonne ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh pas mal, une très bonne raison de mettre dès maintenant (un pouce bleu quoi)!
Merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce joyeux bordel !
Alors on a ouvert absolument tous les colis!
peu importe leurs tailles peu importe leur nature!
Je pensais vraiment pas à en recevoir autant!
et mine-de-rien, ça me fait plaisir de voir que vous jouez le jeu, que vous m'envoyez pleins de colis!
Encore merci ça m'a bien fait délirer!
Si vous voulez que ce Diamond Buton en pâte à sel,
se transforme en vrai trophée des dix millions d'abonnés, et bah abonnez-vous à ma chaîne on n'est très bientôt dix millions!
Vous pouvez également cliquer sur le gros bouton au milieu de votre écran pour vous abonnés à la chaîne "NORMAN FAIT DES VIDEO", et retrouvez à gauche une autre vidéo de Norman "être CH'TI"!!
Sous titre : KAYLES LARECH
Vous pouvez également cliquer sur le gros bouton au milieu de votré écran pour vous abonner à la chaîne "Norman fait des vidéos" et retrouvez à gauche une autre vidéo de Norman "être CH'TI"